okay this should be
live we're testing some new stuff
[Music]
see audio Yep looks like we're
good perfect
Let's uh do a couple quick things and
then we'll check on the
okay got a green screen now
we don't have good enough lighting for
it to work perfectly you can see a
little bit of artifacting but I can't
really do too much about that I might
get something better uh we'll see about
that but for now this is a decent
setup for now this is a decent setup
um let's look at some experiments
so there's one somewhat unfortunate
thing that happened with this uh this
set of experiments
this is weird uh we'll have to relog
into
this one unfortunate thing is I think we
did introduce
a possibility for this thing to just get
stuck looping so we didn't get as many
experiments as I would have
this seems like it's been working so far
though or maybe not maybe this is still
stuck
huh let's see what we manag to get on
the uh on the sweeps so we'll start
with I want to see how these Atari
sweeps
went because we should have finished um
beam Rider right
five days
ago not quite actually beam Rider is
still not quite done it looks
like hopefully this one isn't
stuck I should double check on this one
actually because when hold on when was
this duration 2 minutes 50
seconds 118 oh no this is recent okay
perfect this is it's still going
we've had so many hardware and
stabilities with the Intel
chips that I get
concerned uh yeah but this is
nutty did we have this one yesterday I
don't think
so a crazy good
result it's weird to me that there's one
outlier that's that
different but we will let this finish we
can see this clear Trend over time
I'm also noticing with
carbs
um the algorithm is performing well but
it's not performing quite as well as I
would expect in the sense that it's not
it's not making the experiments long
enough um it should if it the way carbs
is supposed to work is that as it gets
more confident in its results it should
produce longer and longer experiments
I'm not quite seeing that happen though
I mean it's gone up to 50 million steps
but it's not doing anything longer than
that it looks
reasonable and yeah as we can see here
so I tried to do a sweep on the Moa here
we got five experiments and then it
crashed or it hung I should say and now
this one is one experiment in
hanging do we get anything out of this
at
least not
really well that's
unfortunate I would have really liked to
have had a sweep to start on for today
but I guess what we're going to do is
we're going to have to figure out where
this thing is looping we'll start a
sweep up or something and
um I mean we have a bunch of other stuff
we can do on this today though this does
kind of throw a wrench do a few
things
yeah all right let's get started on this
then
so let me just see
which window we have on
stuff
um just make sure we're on the remote
one
we also have stuff potentially for GPU
Drive I should check on today so maybe
we'll do like a hodg podge of random
stuff I do want to make sure that we
have the m in a good spot to start
though because that needs to really get
going and be automated by now um yeah so
I'm a little confused as to where this
is possibly messing up
because the one spot I thought that
there was like a potential for
something is this XP range that I
introduced
on yeah right here so I had before for
the first sweep I had this thing where
it would exit out if it had an invalid
uh if there like there were no valid
targets somehow which shouldn't be
possible but I figured maybe and then I
added this check in
here just to make sure that nothing
weird was happening and still
failing I wish there were a way that we
could add a debugger to this somehow
if I compile this with debug flags on if
I compile this in profile mode will I
get a scyon stack trace or
no I think I should
right if I just like put this profile
flag to true
hopefully I get to see where the uh
where this is actually
failing it's interesting as well that it
is learning
let me fix a couple stream elements real
quick
um I'm still not exactly sure how I want
to set stuff up with the
new overlays and
such what have you been up to in the
past few days I've mostly been
attempting to balance this
MOA and see if we can get some initial
uh reinforcement learning experiments on
this and it went very well yesterday we
actually we managed to pretty much
automatically balance the entire thing
because we had the agents just learn
what skills were good and what skills
were not and that let us iterate very
very
quickly so uh I was hoping that we would
have an overnight sweep run that would
just tell us everything that is happened
with it and like get us a new set of
good policies um but it seems that
somehow I somehow introduced a way for
this thing to get stuck in a loop I
don't exactly know how or where so we
have to track that down what was
imbalanced everything man there were so
many bugs so many things that we had to
change like this would have been months
of work in the past but just the fact
that we had a decent hyper pram sweep so
we had decent settings and then I could
just retrain the agents in 10 minutes it
made everything way way easier it was
pretty cool
actually it's a little tricky because I
don't actually know where and if this is
going to get
stuck hey man hope your week's going
good you
too thanks for dropping
by so I got I got the green screen right
and now I'm trying to figure out where I
want to put the chat and stuff
because I kind of want to have two
windows but it's not
working like
this I could just for now keep the old
settings let's just do like
this go back to
here I will
whoops this
yeah I it's just it's not like you can't
see through it and it's blocking the
code so we'll put this
here
at I don't know puffer goes
somewhere puffer is going to block the
code then yeah puffer can block the chat
instead of the code
I know I'll I'll figure something a
little bit nicer out eventually for
this I kind of just started like
broadcasting my work for fun and then it
turns out that people like to watch very
very slow development for some reason
so non-stop scon study since your
recommendation yeah it's it's very nice
it's also a gateway to lower level
programming as well because it's not
that far off of c um did you see this
snake
en so I ported the snake and to Pure
C and you can play it in the browser
demo yeah I'll link it it's just it's on
puffer AI GitHub IO um so this is 500
lines pure C and
you can play this wherever it's
nice that's one you can play yeah yeah
so the I'm the gold snake the gold snake
in here the yellow one
right and if I just take my hands off
the keyboard the RL will take
over so this is a fun demo it's on the
main website now
technically anything that I've made
could pretty easily be ported to this
unfortunately it does have to be raw C
instead of cython but I'm not asking
contributors to do c because yeah um
there's no performance reason to write
it in C versus scon like there's no
performance reason to do it it's
perfectly fast either way it's just like
the nice oh you could do it on the web
though right
so that's
fun sometimes I like to leave this up as
like a performance like a toy
somewhere honestly the C is not that bad
I I rather enjoyed it
it's only 500 lines total it's really
not any longer than the original demo
was funnily enough
C++ I would way rather write C than C++
to be
honest I hate C+
plus um because it's just a kitchen sync
programming language there's just too
much garbage in it build systems are
annoying
doesn't really add too many things I
want people say like oh but
there's but memory management right you
literally you just have to call a free
after you call Malik it's not hard and
you can just compile with clang and
there's a compile option that will just
tell you whenever you're leaking memory
and it will tell you exactly where
you're leaking memory so if you have
some reasonable compile time tools it's
very
easy we just programing C++ but only use
C Li I don't know I don't want the extra
build system and
stuff what language did you start in
it depends how seriously you mean I
guess technically like some weird action
script but I didn't know what I was
doing there so I guess
Java and then mat lab and then
Python and then I learned C++ and then C
and assembly all the lower level stuff
and then I had to do some random stuff
in JavaScript I also had to do like
random Arduino stuff at some
point vast majority of stuff I've
written is in python
Python I don't know I'm looking I'm
looking forward to picking up more C
stuff
I'm pretty picky with the stuff all
working as
well the two I have like zero interest
whatsoever in trying our um or picking
up rather our typescript and uh
rust those are the two I just do not
want to touch ever
I think I'm going to have to manually
figure out why this thing is freaking
looping because it's not going to it's
not going to produce me a stack Trace
quickly
enough it's got to be like a while
somewhere
right this is the only while loop in the
program
right is there something else that would
cause it to get stuck like if one of the
processes crashed or
something there's too much stuff running
in this stack for me to
know I really thought it would be the
um the XP bug
it can't be this this is this has run
like billions of experiments on this
code or billions of steps of experiments
on this code it's got to be the XP bug
like
right but I don't see where where there
would be any opportunity for this to
break there was a divide by zero here
but I fixed that
I really don't see where this would be
bad R I don't
know it's very
odd and I don't really want to get stuck
debugging like something for three hours
at the start of the stream
either
um let me think what directions we can
take here so
H is it
stuck I think it just got
stuck so how do I get a trace out of
this I think I can
just can I just kill this and get a
trace are you serious I compiled this
thing with profiling on
let's just do
this oh I made the window to yeah here
this has got to go way up to here
right yeah okay so we'll run this
locally
it's kind of annoying you losing that
much screen real estate I'm going to
have to find a way to like do this that
I don't lose that much screen real
you know how like games streamers have
um like the donation
overlays I kind of want one that's uh
like Star overlay who's the last person
that starred puffer lib on
interestingly enough these settings do
appear to be learning stuff even though
they're not tuned for the latest
setting these seem to be generally
good let me see how do I get a stack
Trace set
[Music]
set that could be
I got to find a better way to structure
these piece of code this piece of code's
really
we make sure we're not double counting
the main
player we reward we reward the current
player I wouldn't think that this would
be it
though because we clear this
manually it could technically mess some
stuff up but this is like accounting for
a situation that shouldn't be able to
happen
anyways or or is it actually no wait
this is this is a very common situation
actually isn't it a very common
situation okay I think I should spend a
little bit of time to actually just make
this piece of code not
garbage that's probably a good use of
time
um let me think if there's a better way
to do
I think you do have to iterate over
stuff twice because you don't know how
many allies you're sharing with until
you know how many are in range
and I don't want to redo the distance
check
oh you know what's
weird the thing that is weird is that
this should never
trigger the reason that it's hard to
write this code is because I'm writing
code for an impossible circumstance
like I'm calculating I see what could
happen so technically
like you have a range in which you can
get
XP but like let's say that you're you
fire an AOE at the end the edge of your
attack range
then you could potentially be outside of
XP range the thing that you kill could
be out of X your own XP range so nobody
gets the XP but that's
weird so I guess we leave this like this
for now we fix the we fix the issue or
at least it should be
fixed it's interesting that it's not
finding the buug
well I want to actually compare total
levels
gained let me see what uh what like a
typical total levels gained was from
last the experiments I ran last time
you can simplify
stuff maybe
allies I still need a static data
structure for him right there's no
like I'd have to like exclude my own
index or something the logic for that I
think it'd be messy
okay so here this is we're getting 300
levels this thing actually says that the
it's leveling up
more what about
happening this is stuff is definitely
happening I guess we just have to like
train finish training this hope it
doesn't crash and then load this policy
and watch it and see if it looks
interesting YouTube strikes again I
don't know why it does
that I don't have any custom settings on
it I don't have it in like a slow mode
or
and it in range of
players count to one
I have toit this to five and subtract
don't
I it's a little awkward you have just
init this to
five you still can't do
this we can no you can do this actually
well because you always have one of them
set to true and you always have you
can't
one can't use index
unfortunately that's
funny I wish I could disable that stuff
I don't know where the settings are for
do I would actually rather
like this is just so weird that I'd
rather do it like
this and have five things here and and
it this to zero and then I would just
this cuz it's weird to like it's weird
to be counting down like just declare
everything is in range until proven
otherwise is
weird so
now oh I see yeah this is what I
like this isn't
terrible there still an obnoxious amount
of code for like something this simple
but uh according to this it says the
model is not that
really is it there's no slash route
right just
doing
Docker really thought this would be
class tune in tomorrow go to sleep see
you
around I'm on late today had to do some
stuff and set this up well the thing
that's invisible behind me the green
anything don't really do very much do
they
that could be because of the reward
stuff though before we did fix some
issues how do we just go even with the
wave that's weird it's a crashed in
Tower I
why now the tower is going to start
chunking me if I'm not careful like that
it just chunked me twice
oh
interesting is
this look this uh this one's actually
farming okay so we need to fix some
reward stuff
but yeah look at this what class is this
is it the Assassin yeah this is the
Assassin so the Assassin's actually kind
of learn to Jungle a little bit that's
cool hey no killing Towers
cool let's recompile this um this
version with the fix and see if it does
any
better we'll have to figure out some
other stuff to do with this
we'll track this one as well
what
uh oh here we
go track this one and then while that
trains I will check a couple other
things on the
side because it's possible that we will
have GPU Drive fixes to look
it looked like I might have to do a
thing I didn't want to have to
do there's a bug in the freaking one of
the dependencies of a environment I have
a binding
open how's puffer doing on the star
count 818
wow that is
solid where did it go
I was just looking at a thing where did
it
go oh
okay so here
is our
experiment as expected it takes longer
to train it looks like right
it takes like 30 million steps for it to
figure out that it needs to be doing
stuff and it starts to take
off it's actually kind of funny that the
tank is the one that levels the fastest
now maybe the tank has learned to um to
Jungle right the tank has really really
good
clear I mean we balanced it yesterday
yesterday based off of
um a different
reward we B balanced it based off of a
reward that was just run it down mid
we'll see what these guys are doing now
but that's pretty cool
how how we move the project forward from
here obviously I'm going to need a sweep
that doesn't
crash so we'll hopefully pick that bug
out at some point
today we see how this
does Hero kills are going up
nicely yeah this is it's learning stuff
for
sure though it's quite possible that the
um that they're not all learning as
you'd want them
to damage dealt though those curves are
looking good
good do we have
objectives
level skill usages are mostly going up
as we'd expect we're starting to get
reward for taking
Towers what
else yeah we're starting to get the
towers being taken
[Music]
here XP reward is very nice
radiant
victories it looks like very very dire
biased isn't
it I got to figure out why it's so dire
biased I think it's because there's a
way to glitch through the
terrain I'll have to check into that for
some reason the map is like very very
dire
biased shouldn't be but it
is and then
[Music]
oh this is funny so they are actually
dying
more but this is expected they're
playing the game
right it' be worse if they were just
sitting at
oh it looks like they're actually
learning to catch up
now the carry is going to be a lot
steeper right the other curves yeah they
should get steeper I mean that's what we
would expect I think that this is just
like the tank is has has an easier kit
to
learn tank literally has it has a bunch
of HP it has a full heal and it has a
button that it can just use to do AOE
damage to like clear mobs and it's no
cool down so I think that probably this
is just like easier to learn to
play we shouldn't necessarily take the
training curves um as the sign of
balance it needs to be the eval time
curves so the trained models when you
run the trained models in the game what
level they end
up he
will how's it going
hey will you should you should get one
of these giant ass green screens that
takes up your entire
is this
Frozen no it's still
good it's not slower is it no it's still
like three 300K steps per second which
is it's a slower train setting but it's
still
good
and do we have the victory count
increasing
still Level
so you can see that some of these
metrics are dipping but the tower metric
actually
increased I'm pretty sure this is not a
bad thing I'm pretty sure a bunch of
games just finished as
all yeah you can see like
I'm pretty sure it's just a bunch of
games are
finishing Tower taken metric has spiked
up a
bit so we'll see if these models are any
good but this does look very
reasonable and it's cool like that a lot
of these curves have pretty much just
reversed the support is still low kills
which which is what we expect
right ah the carry does scale look the
carry did outscale the burst
character and the Assassin so these
three are good uh apparently the tank is
just ridiculously good when you actually
learn how to farm with
it I'm guessing we're going to see the
tank farming some stuff we'll see I
could be
wrong probably we're still going to see
everybody just running down
mid like I doubt we're going to get play
on all three lanes but
maybe that'll be really cool as soon as
we get that
lanes where' this will guy go what's he
doing
he I think this is no longer alive
right
yeah short
streams stream game too short
I was going to go say hi while I wait
for this to train
it's not done
yet these level crashes are very
sketchy is it un wait is it unlearning
stuff or is it just games hold
on this is
important Tower reward is crashing this
is bad
I bet you if I bet you I can tell you
why I bet the losses
there's this huge spike in value loss
right
here maybe this is
it yeah I think
generally carbs tends to find these
really yeah the policy loss is broken so
carbs tends to find these like really
weird
settings um that
are very good but
unstable it's like it'll find these
really aggressive hyper pram
that just get to be
unstable it's interesting that it
actually got slower as well that's
weird I don't even know how that's
possible
according to this this model still does
stuff but I think we're probably going
to have to
eval multiple checkpoints
reward reward XP went up like crazy
right
here hey harry
welcome back to back I'm usually live
five days a week at least
hours I bought a gigantic green screen
that takes up my entire room
though not A+ yeah we'll keep upgrading
stuff over over time we'll keep
upgrading which wait where am I should I
be
doing you guys are wasting way too much
time down
here let's see let's watch what they do
uniform okay this is the Assassin
character trying to farm but being weird
about
it we also might want to try the
intermediate
models there's the carry also attempting
to farm and being weird about
it at least they have figured out that
they are supposed to farm in some way
shape or form
right of course like not as effective as
me just going up and like hitting all
these with all my Mana that pushes the
wave but know these are high level
tactics can't expect him to do this
immediately
yeah so there we go we killed
one now we're level
two we drop uh W on this entire group
right don't we have any AOE stun as well
we should have like a literal like giant
[ __ ] off AOE stun don't
we I don't have Mana for it there we go
yeah kills him
cool so let's try copying the earlier
Model
50 I don't think this one's early enough
but we'll try
it I mean I don't think it's late enough
but we'll try it see if it looks any
better I mean we really need to just run
the hyper pram site sweep on this
stuff yo look at this guy he look at
this one go okay well this one's doing
stuff
right he just ran just running it down
mid y you need some help there
Mana they definitely learn
stuff they definitely learn
stuff we also might have to consider the
network size at some point relatively
soon so yeah there's our burst attack
right we can do this we don't have Mana
for the AOE stun they're actually going
to kill us if we just try to take the
whole group like this aren't
yeah the Assassin character is like
really good you can see it just zip
around
[Music]
everywhere all right I like this um I
definitely like
this do I just risk running the sweep or
what do I do
I guess we just have to risk running the
sweep for
now yeah I don't want to add too many
variables at
once so we'll just do this for now and
we'll see if it's stable after the
changes that I've made
okay so there's the sweep queued up um
I'm trying to think how much stuff there
is that we can do on the on this project
for now while this is going to be
uh the sweeps are going to be an issue I
think that what we're going to do here
let me turn the AC down and then like
take two actually two minutes and then
I'll uh I'll go over the plan for the
rest of the day and I think we're going
to be able to do some fun stuff and make
this like more properly a
if I want to do more stuff on this
project for the time being at least
while I'm waiting on this stuff to see
if it's getting stuck or not
um we could do some fun stuff with
the the graphics and the Ant the systems
today I mean today's a short work day
for me anyways just because I had a
bunch of other stuff so I wouldn't mind
just trying to like figure out a way to
make this thing fun and
visually interesting and also just more
interpretable
so yeah why don't we just have some fun
and figure out how to do some of that
side of stuff today
um you know I wanted to start with let's
start with something slightly technical
maybe and let's just like mess around
with RB a bit and see if their ways to
do some of the things I'm thinking of um
yeah
versions I just saw that uh rayon had
like a cool
Shader thing that he did that I want to
play
with what P what is puffer what are you
building
all right sure um so so all the other so
I you probably saw neural MMO
right so the story is I finished my PhD
I've spent I've been in AI for 10 years
I spent seven years building neural MMO
uh I've picked up a bunch of stuff on
like working with complicated games and
complicated Sims in general and how to
make that actually work in reinforcement
learning so now that I'm out of Academia
I'm working on prct practical stuff to
make reinforcement learning Ultra Ultra
fast and work on all sorts of different
complicated Sims and I'm doing this full
time
so what I'm doing at the moment is one
of the simulators that I'm building for
use with for experimentation in uh in
puffer and it is a strip down version of
like DOTA it's a strip down mooba and
the goal is to do a mini version of this
project open AI 5 it's like a very mini
version of this project where the
opening I5 team beat worldclass top pros
at DOTA I consider this to be the best
result by far in reinforcement learning
uh I was interning there when they were
building this I was like 20 ft away from
them and it was awesome awesome team
just doing awesome work um and the thing
is it's like they had so much
infrastructure it was so heavy it was
like a th000 gpus and 100,000 CPUs and
it was just hard to do that type of
stuff um and it's really hard to do that
type of stuff at personal scale so what
I'm doing now is uh I'm doing like a
full
MOBA it has Towers creep waves neutrals
levels skills all that stuff maybe no
economy at least for the time being but
am MOA and I'm using this some of the
techniques that I have come up with to
make this thing run at like a million
FPS so instead of having to have this be
a th000 gpus we can get some cool
results on one
GPU that's what I'm building I build a
lot of other stuff with puffer um if you
want to play around with something
simple but
interactive this is reinforcement
learning agents running in your browser
in C so you can play Snake versus RL
agents control the yellow snake or
whatever um I also have some other Sims
as well and yeah it's a big open source
project and all the stuff is here right
in PU and you can start to help me out
helps me a
ton huge to get that kind of Hardware wi
yeah this is the idea we don't have a
ton of hardware for this uh for this or
yet I did put together this well I set
up this
like Jank garage cluster with eight
desktops so this is what we've been
using for our stuff so far um but yeah
the the emphasis with puffer is just on
Ultra ultra high performance stuff while
keeping things very very
simple where was Ray on Ray he had a
tweet that I wanted to he had a tool I
wanted to use to play around with
shaders oh perfect do I actually get to
use oh cool I get to actually give this
guy
money wait how did he do this he made
the picture a link
Twitter who would be the end user of
this so it's a combination of stuff part
of this is me wanting to build just cool
open- Source stuff that will be
beneficial for researchers in RL and be
I mean the goal is my real goal is to
just like transform the field right
revolutionize reinforcement learning
Ultra Ultra highperformance Sims
automated experiments really nice tools
ease of use with really high-end complex
simulators and environments um but the
idea is going to be that for companies
you know all the tools are free and open
source but we will sell extras Services
mostly support type stuff uh so that the
company can also get some revenue and I
can start scaling up some cool stuff
around it that's the plan
I think that's how stable diffusion run
as
well
um kind of except they took a ton of VC
money and kind and did a bunch of
sketchy stuff and got screwed they
actually screwed uh yeah whatam what's
the org stability they kind of screwed
me out of 300K worth of compute so I'm
not too happy with them
lie
okay
oops I have to log
in there we
go how' they screw you so I ran a
competition on neural MMO and I put
together a proposal for them cuz they
were funding like open source stuff and
I put the proposal together with the
compute allocated in mind so they said
that we would get 150k a00 hours for the
competition they delivered less than 10%
of that they drugg their feet on the
infrastructure and then they pulled all
the compute and ultimately they caused
me and the team hundreds to hundreds to
I'd say well over a thousand actually
hours of additional work most of which
nobody actually made any money off of at
all so yeah that was not a fun
time I know I haven't like blasted him a
ton about that because the one guy that
I was working with directly he also got
screwed uh Lewis was awesome but yeah
they they did some sketchy
I'm actually very happy to be able to
pay this
guy
um what's the license for
this ah why the [ __ ] did this open in
freaking VSS code I do not ever want you
to open VSS code again
already I just wanted to play with this
and I I thought we could make some
shaders and stuff for the
project is
this Zoom
good this is uh from rayon he wrote a
like a rapper around his some of his
Tech he made like a Shader editor and a
few other things and I wanted to play
around with some shaders and I wanted an
excuse to give this guy some money
because he does really awesome work and
I love RB so I figured we'd do some of
this on stream because we've got like
we've got stuff to wait on
here why is this a th ELO wait
what that
ELO that's
weird I guess it doesn't do anything
good
huh this is running though so we'll let
this we'll let this run in the
background and I'll check in on this
periodically
load a new image into
project
okay oh I see I see how this
works this is going to we're going to
use this as a Shader editor I just
wanted to make I wanted to do something
cool so I want to make a I want to make
a cool Shader for the
map
one
okay so if can I load this
in I'm also the reason the other reason
I'm doing this right now is because um I
want to see what like guies look like
built with
Ray and so far I love the style of this
app
thing yeah and he actually has a style
button which is like how many apps do
this it's just like yeah we just there's
seven of them you can just choose
yeah this is like this guy just makes
amazing software why doesn't I cuz not
everybody is RA like Ray on so he's the
developer of rib which is he makes like
single file C header libraries like
header only C libraries single file that
is like hey let's just fix all of
Graphics here here you go Free Library
it's one C
file I use it for everything
now oh you can take the Border off as
well that's
sweet wait toggle Window topmost mode so
like this won't go over this is so
funny can you link that program page
this one is paid uh most of his stuff is
open
source this he has a few paid
things it's
wait what does he
say
enjoying oh I it might be like a pay
what you want thing I think the default
is 20 bucks I don't know I paid him 20
bucks it's worth way more than that his
stuff is worth so much more than
that if we if I like yeah I it's he
makes such good
stuff window transparent
mode oh cool he has commands on here is
there a way to like increase the scale
of this it doesn't increase the size of
like this is draggable but I would like
to be able to increase the UI scale
edit where's the Shader editor thing
like how do I do
this do you have like a tutorial or
something on
it oh wait does he have it on the web oh
that's so cracked he literally has it on
the web you can play with it on the web
and then you can download it to own it
that's
awesome yeah cuz it's all C so it all
compiles to web assembly so he just has
it on the
web I love this guy's
work God this is so
good yeah this is so FYI this is how my
this is how I made
this this is made with RB
now you might say that's just a snake
game who cares while the reinforcement
learned agents running in that snake
game in real time and it runs even on
your phone it's nice and
fast 100% in browser as
well see if you can figure out how you
do shaders with this thing and if I can
figure out how to like increase the
scale of the
provided how's this freaking thing work
man
bindings there're like a few things I
want with this I want this to have Vim
key bindings does it
have well whatever I'll play with it in
here for now it's really weird editing
text without him though I'm so used to
it
snake game is awesome oh those snakes
are like substantially nerfed compared
to the ones you can train in puffer Leb
like those are nerfed into the ground
basically because I didn't want to
implement uh convolution and lstm layers
for web yet so they have a really dumb
architecture they can be much smarter
than that mate much much smarter
uh I have not written shaders in 6 years
and I haven't written that many to begin
with so I this is one of the rare cases
where I am actually going
to generate some llm
slop very very rare I know I hate
generating llm slop but I do not know
what I'm
hate to see how the tough one
wait how
the yeah no you you basically just don't
win against good RL agents
this guy just builds such good
software like I actually I wish all
software were as good as what this guy
makes this is like so
smooth freaking just pure C
code I love this it's got like this cool
retro art style if you're boring you
know there's like you can turn it to be
like more normal if you're boring
right I love
this okay so we are we're just copy
pasting sloth
now
uhoh I just said the software is really
good it crashed uh rayon is not supposed
to do that I assume
fluke let's blame Windows instead of
blaming Ray on
confused he also has a sound
generator that's awesome
stream I I don't know what I'm doing
here I have not written shaders in
forever but okay I'll tell you what I'm
trying to do okay so there there are two
things I'm trying to do here at the same
time one is to play around with a goey
written with Ray to see if I like their
gooey stuff in order to like make my
goys with later on and I think that this
looks amazing so check mark for that uh
the second thing is I actually want to
make
something which is uh I wanted to make I
wanted to like upscale this image by a
fixed amount and then I want to do a
Shader effect where like I color the
edges of the uh like the pixel edges
differently basically I wanted to do
like an edge detect thing where I like
you know I do like a smooth blender
whatever and I want to make it cool
so this thing just wrote me a wrong
Shader which is what I get for using a
language model hopping for a meeting see
you
around don't you hate when devs have to
have
meetings this looks very similar to a
DOTA map this is the DOTA
map this is the DOTA
map.png we're using this for the
mooba oh thanks twitch let me ban that
bot real quick
of so claud's just stupid right
like isn't it just
this no this was not what it was
wait frag text
factor maybe cla's right and maybe I'm
dumb let's see
whoops claud's really good at writing
bad code as far as I've
seen really great at writing bad
I do not understand how this is supposed
to work
um calculate the scale
factor calculate the original pre-scaled
texture
coordinates it doesn't upscale this
anywhere yeah let's
does what I'm trying to do just not make
sense here
uhoh it's kind of crashy
rayon I'm a bit concerned with that for
weird so Claude doesn't know what the
hell it's doing clearly
why is it changing with zoom because
Claude is dumb
I basically I don't know if you've seen
this stream before but I basically I
will only ever
use um like llm stuff when I have
absolutely no idea what I'm doing so I
have not written a Shader since
the like first year of my PhD so I
haven't written a Shader in five
let me go check what uh color I want to
make these and then we should check on
our sweep as well real quick to make
sure it's not
confused let me just see if it has any
idea what it's doing or if it just
doesn't know how to write Traders at
all this is like such a well-designed
program I don't know why it's
crashy like race like rayon never writes
like any that's broken so I don't know
why the hell this is
crashy it's
crazy luckily we're not losing
anything okay perfect so this
works um
maybe I've just I haven't been I've been
using this for like half an hour so I
don't know
let's see if it can do this
and if so I'll try to like understand
what the
oh I see I think the scale is being used
to
crash where does it handle
scale
zero Hey Roman what's
up oh I should check this to make sure
this hasn't crashed before I
forget nope hasn't crashed
on this is such a good viewer if it just
weren't this
crashy I'm not losing any work luckily
it's just like it's annoying
is puffer op they're pretty op we're
training them without the distance
reward now so hopefully they'll like
they should learn to Jungle and maybe
even use other lanes what did I press
command Z or control Z I
guess it's just very crashy I don't know
it's a really really solid program it
just needs to not be crashy
yeah but just look at this thing this is
like an awesome application
like I wish all software were
this but maybe not
crashing five ipas in
jeez that was me
like that was me in like undergrad or
the let's be honest a couple years into
PhD as
well and then I stopped that
[ __ ] I stopped doing that
extra bad at mobas right
now how's the MOBA work I missed like
four weeks oh the MOBA is
cool so we basically Auto balanced
everything yesterday by just like
retraining it like making balance
changes and then retraining the Moa
repeatedly and uh the only thing is that
we ran into some bugs with the sweep so
we didn't get to fully redo a sweep
overnight okay perfect this is what we
wanted 211z
I guess you don't care about the rank
otherwise you would have stopped playing
right
um this is just set up to be like a
specific resolution huh
do you play moiz or just build I've
played a very small amount of DOTA and a
little bit of League uh I don't really
have that much time to play tons of
games these days
um but I mean I was always an MMO junkie
when I
did I don't know I have maybe like
couple hundred two three hundred hours
of League maybe 100 hours of DOTA at
most
less I
do enough to know the basics of like how
to build one not enough to understand
the nuances right
I'm trying to think
what how I want to build
this it'd be really cool to just do this
all as a
Shader good amount of interesting team
play moas oh yeah I'm well aware I
consider I understand like I I spent I
took a week off just to try to like
understand DOTA as best I could before
open AI played versus uh OG and based on
that and the complexity of that game I
consider the best result ever achieved
in reinforcement
learning by
far web version doesn't
crash that's weird it's the it's it
should be the same code like the way
that he does stuff it's just uh it's web
assembly this whole thing is
C it's probably Windows being stupid
let's be
honest so how wait I'm so confused as to
how I do this
I guess I just have to do it this way
for now
IPA numbers
jeez geez
let's see if this
works once a few
months fair
enough I definitely had a period of time
where it was once a few days for
me I had to quit
that turns out that's not a good
why this doesn't show you the errors the
obnoxious
thing is there like a com like a console
or
something text to speech was a little
better oh that's what you're doing
that's
funny I thought you were just like drunk
typing on a thing and not being able to
type it was funnier when I thought of it
that
I'd like to know
[Music]
why you're just griefing ranked G games
that's
funny how many people are currently here
watching me not know what a Shader
is nobody
perfect I'd like to figure out what the
heck is wrong with this
this is the world world's worst invented
workflow just like not understanding
anything and just pacing stuff into AI
it's got to be the like the dumbest
workflow
um yeah I'm going to just have to write
this myself and figure it out I think
because this is like dumb
is there something wrong with this
editor because I had
valid this was valid
before I might have posted did I like
did it get mangled when I pasted it
you ought to try
playing I did I played plenty
I do occasionally play stuff for
um for research purposes but I play them
a heck of a lot less right than I
usually I otherwise
anything okay let me see what this thing
was trying to
do this is the worst UI ever designed
what the [ __ ]
okay
[Music]
any less
builtins
so hang on
this one actually looks valid
let's let's take
this resolution and then what does this
do I don't care about
not having an error I is does glsl
normally give you reasonable errors let
me
where's frag
color this doesn't
exist so I think just this is this is a
combination of me not what's not knowing
what's going on and um
man this is just
bizarre I understand what's going on
what's going on is just um basically
language models being dog
[ __ ] um
because like this is just this is doing
[ __ ] that makes no
sense there so now this
if this does not run I'm just going to
close Claude because it's making me mad
and frankly language models are stupid
and useless
oh yeah it just added a bunch of lines
of code and did nothing goodbye
Claude let's actually write our own code
we'll have to learn something for once
oh
no I don't even know why I
h how do I do this
effect maybe I should just I'll I know
I'll go find
Edge
intensity they did a soble for Edge
detection this should be substantially
simpler
so I'm going to use this as a
reference and I'm going to make this
substantially
simpler where's the lookup
how are you even typing all this mid
game
I
see e
I hate having to use [ __ ] language
models for
is
why
color 18 G Ren streak not looking
good well yeah no
[ __ ] h
this should
be right yeah
wait number of
pixels what's distance
glow oh it's scale
overlow isn't it wait
scale glow over scale is 0.25
chord you divide by
8 you add a quarter of a pixel
you can drink and have fun you just
can't
shift uh I'm going to paste this in but
I think this is wrong
man wait you divide by the scale factor
of
is
0.25 .25 to the
right the carry and the puffer m is
Loosely based on
Caitlyn it's like kind of a combination
of Caitlyn and Ash I gave her like the
jump back that the net
has for
okay so this actually did
something
eight this means that you get the top
eight portion
of your
cheese isn't that
like depending on what you're drinking
then you're getting into like lethal
amounts of alcohol there
right
distance
glow 10
260 but this is not skilled
right oh maybe the fragment cord is
scaled
I see so it gave me one bad piece of
information and I thought it was a
different P bad piece of information
five 25
okay so I no longer need
D
okay I want to copy all this just in
ones black pixels to sign other way
around
okay very
good
down and we may as well finish
this
cell left
right Star Puffer welcome linky yep doar
puffer it's all on GitHub we're doing
some weird stuff at the moment
things it's a little awkward having the
uh the puffer here isn't
it up go up there Puffer
chat can go up
here
uper
there's got to be a better way of doing
this
I think the way I was doing it before
was kind of okay
it's just like very annoying in
verbos let's just stick with that
I mean I should just be able to write a
little Loop
yeah I think this Loop is going to be
like shitty or something I don't
know it's it's like annoying to me I
just don't understand like Shader
intricacies so I'm going to
do
copy
paste write
down this will
be
up
dist left
be okay so we have all
these and then we'll just do
it's going to
be right
Hey
Thomas
here we'll get GPT to find the syntax
error
is border has multiple unmatched
parentheses thank you
wait yeah this is I just can't see this
in Tex freaking errors because there's
no syntax highlighting on this as all
wait are these are these actual tab
characters jeez we'll have to mess with
that okay this works
weird
huh 16 times time
five yeah there we go that's a game map
right
that we're going to have to make the
effect a little more
though oh this is supposed to be 1.0
this why is weird
do so sign
is + onega 1
.5 so it's
7525 I
Shader I wonder if there's anything we
can do to make it
I'm generally
PR I'm going to go I'm going to use the
rest from real quick and then what we're
going to do is we're going to try to
figure out how I can integrate this with
uh with the
game this will like substantially Jazz
up the map a little bit
right so it just won't be like so static
and
leaving trails on agents could be
interesting I don't know how to do it is
the
problem I so I basically I wanted to do
this in order to get the first Shader
into the project so that um if anybody
knows what the hell they're doing with
shaders they can contribute some cool
stuff let me make this slightly let me
think I think this is good we'll do this
to start
with
um I want to do math here science
whatsoever okay so how do we integrate a
Shader
with uh
Ray I don't
know examples
comp I'm just going to think probably
you
okay oh wait what this
is you can do shade oh yeah so
Shader where's the
Shader okay this is what I was looking
for
guess okay we we're going to have to fix
that bug Unfortunately today um but I
want to I I'm going to do the stupid
thing right now cuz I want to finish
this
oops okay so let's do self Dot Game map
game map
path code
Shader
pass over
Shader and then we'll
do
Shader load
Shader it's got to be it's like
zero the string and then glsl
I'm trying to think how I want to do
this how' you get that background what
this
oh uh hold on I'll show
how did you know you can go on Amazon
and buy things
will you can just go on Amazon and buy
things
shaders not an inclin
Village are you still in
Tahoe I thought you're no longer in
Tahoe
see I we should meet up sometime and
like hack on something or whatever it'
be
that first week was rough when you were
on the stream last week I literally just
was not functioning at
all actually managed to like burn out
all my neurons it's
ridiculous and The Sweep is
stuck oh yeah I think we like solve
Atari um not like agent 57 level or
anything but I think we just smoke all
the existing like Po implementations
just with Hyper prams that's fun used to
run
Ultras is
solid I don't know it's
like I'm still going to do distances but
but I want to I missed my strength
training I want to get my uh my four
plate pull back and then you know build
back up to the marathon plus distances
with the four plate pull not training
not doing like substantial lower body
strength work just
sucks any surprising hyper parameters oh
yeah this finds like completely
unintuitive hyp like this thing is nuts
carbs finds just psychotic hyper
parameters that just completely diverge
if you train them for longer but like it
essentially finds these really really
aggressive settings that are just a for
long enough to give you the run and like
get the reward and you if you train for
any longer they collapse it's
crazy okay so here this tuning is
working it's just there's something I
managed to make an infinite Loop
somewhere I guess I don't know where
or maybe not wait this only have been up
eight
450 where's the
stuck this could just be doing evals
right I think it could just be doing
evals we'll leave it for now
4:14 wait 4:14 that's not 8
minutes damn it show me some wacky pams
for
Atari I don't know what are these
uh wrong one if you used to run Ultras
well you might get a kick out of the uh
I put an article on X with it it was
amusing
here let's see if the let's just see I
bet you the breakout one is
nutty I mean that the beam Rider one is
probably nutty let's
see if I go to losses
where the loss
is oh yeah how's this for a value
loss so we have a 400 something value
loss somehow this thing is close to 7K
score in less than 15
minutes and then if I look at the prams
let's see what it
has we've got
um value function clipping
coefficient of one but then a value
function coefficient so the value
function is basically not getting
trained at all
03 it has a really big Max grad norm and
then it has like a stupidly high it's
like 3 minus three learn
and it just full
send isn't that
funny and it
works this is what I'm saying like we're
not going to make any prog we're not
going to make any progress in this field
trying to like manually tune these
things it makes no sense
whatsoever we just Auto solve we just
make it faster automatically solve
everything I know it's
[ __ ]
yeah I know I I have also been in RL for
a long time and it's like the hell I
don't know but look look at this look at
this return right it just doesn't need
the value function I
guess he's like I don't know we don't
need a value function Baseline where
we're going
what happens when you keep training so
that's the thing I can't figure out um
carbs is supposed to do longer and
longer experiments as uh as it gets more
confident but for whatever reason it it
will make the experiments longer but it
doesn't keep making them longer and
longer it's weird so carbs isn't quite
doing what it's supposed to be doing
there I might have to make a couple more
tweaks but still we're like we're
crushing all the base lines with like
still having bugs and it it's just good
like this
here the clean RL Baseline for this like
same lstm and everything is like six
plus hours to get a tiny fraction of
this
score and we're doing 14
minutes and we're just crushing it
right it's pretty cool we already did
Breakout breakouts pretty solid I think
breakout needs to be trained for longer
cuz it's like a very syy
environment um but I think in like 25
million steps we get
400ish 393 yeah what if you
take uh unfortunately I don't have I
don't have the number of boxes I would
like to have in order to keep doing that
but yes that is on the menu um I will
tell you
that it does seem like there are better
parameters ERS that are longer but I
will say that some of these like some of
the ones where the value function
explodes it's just a matter of time
before the policy eventually collapses
it kind of
depends I've seen
both it's going to take some additional
analysis I need to get some more boxes
man like Intel just screwed me so hard
with the uh the gen13
chips you always get screwed on Hardware
but yeah this is a nice clean breakout
sweep
right there's the parito front of
breakout so uh what's
this uh three uh 12 minutes or whatever
no 15 minutes less than 15 minutes for
breakout none of these algorithms
actually work doing reinforce is good
enough
maybe but I can tell you what either way
well um we are going to be able to
exhaust exhaustively and conclusively
evaluate that type of stuff for the
first time in rl's history because we're
going to have the MSB fast enough to
actually run comprehensive
experiments Isn't that
cool we're actually going to be able to
run like insanely comprehensive
experiments we have two of the viewers
two of my YouTube viewers uh have done
Atari re-implementations so we now have
breakout and pong that are like 300K
plus steps per second um and they're G
to get even faster than that that's not
from pixels but it's the same game it's
like very closely matched to the
original
Atari
so and like in principle we can pretty
much reimplement whatever we want these
days with a little bit of tuning at a
million plus steps per second per core
so as soon as we just get a bunch of
Sims we're pretty much going to be able
to just like redo all the science that
we want on one GPU
instantly cuz it's that
fast like all these Atari experiments
these came out of me taking the Atari
baselines from like 3K up to 30k so one
order magnitude we have two to three
orders of magnitude with custom M's you
don't feel the pixel part is important
not
really high dimensional input space is a
factor not not
really it's only a factor in the sense
that you have to get the data onto the
GPU and we're looking at ways around
that I don't think High dimensional
input affects anything really dota's
super high dimensional input and that
works with po
right I think dota's like uh 10 kilobyte
OBS or something and pretty big packets
I don't think there really is any
algorithm Choice frankly I think if you
just send it with po until proven
building like you to send it with
vanilla policy gradients
um so actually I I can show you one more
completely unhinged set of hyper prams
so this is before I rebalance the game
and I see this a lot as well
so I have batch size 2 million mini
batch size
30k and four update
Epoch
20 no it's 21 and
then
10 so
uh is that 2 to the
yeah uh it's 2 to the six right I'm
being stupid yeah 64 so times four uh
cuz four update Epoch 256 updates on the
same
data I don't know why it does that and
that's with a simulator that's fast
enough for it to get fresh data
immediately whenever it wants
so there's some weirdness going
work I think you still want
with
discounting yeah maybe it
works there's not really much Advantage
though will because it's not any
faster like vanilla policy gradients
isn't any faster than PPO
and like poo does have this nice
built-in knob for stale
data guarding technical debt
about yeah so there is one thing I'm
suspicious about here will that's like
why I suspect that you actually need po
so po was originally meant to work for
stale data right that's like the thing
it's you have multiple update Epoch on
the same data the data is stale you need
a clipping parameter or whatever right
and then I think I had that thing where
I found a a discrepancy in the original
po paper where it implies that you do um
gradient accumulation over the batches
per Epoch update so you're only doing
Epoch updates number of train steps
but then none of the libraries including
the original implement it that way so
basically the way PO is implemented you
are off policy even if you set update
EPO equal to one so for that reason I
think that you probably do need the
clipping pram and also the clipping pram
is essential to let like carbs discover
these insane sets of hyperparameters
that like basically like uh YOLO a thing
have all the losses explode and still
work up to a point
so I think that yeah you could probably
get some good stuff out of vanilla uh
vanilla policy gradients but I think
that they're like there are other
variables at play that are probably
making po useful but not for the reasons
that the original algorithm was
proposed that's what I think is
happening at the
moment but yeah all this stuff is just
all this stuff is taken off um
I just have so many Sims and so many
experiments and things that I need to be
doing at the same time
um the plan at the moment is I need to I
need to like either this weekend or ASAP
I need to finish this video and like
open puffer for business so that I can
start Jenning some revenue and then once
I have that sort of set up I'll have
that'll kind of free up some ability
to go slower with the Sims and like take
the time I need to really build out the
set of good Sims for the field but yeah
I got to wrap up a few existing things
at the
moment really I just want to like start
new sim projects every other day I've
been somewhat successful in preventing
myself from doing
cool the m is actually kind of
fun it needs to better animations and
stuff but like the classes feel
good oh yeah I found another funny thing
um I had a couple people get mad at me
over the sticky actions
paper uh the sticky actions thing cuz
like H you can't say sticky actions is
broken well guess what the agent 57 from
Deep Mind yeah they don't use sticky
actions either they know what doesn't
work
funny you find lots of skeletons in the
closet if you keep searching for things
it turns out
that's what I've been up to I see you're
still building
stuff I tried doing some stuff with
Claude over the last couple weeks and I
got to be honest I genuinely don't know
how you enjoy it
but teach their own with
that okay you can't say you have to know
how to type a prompt into the llm like
you can't come on
I guess the way I look at it is like
anything that it's capable of is already
easy for me to do anyways and I'll write
better code and like anything it's not
capable of I'm just going to fight with
it like debugging for a while until I
get sick of it and do it myself
ah I'm still bullish on hard skill being
like the most important thing
look honestly this is what's going to
happen right I'm just going to say I'm
just going to keep saying that lm's
write [ __ ] code until they actually do
write good code and then what I'm going
to do is I'm going to say yeah cuz now
they can write good code because they
were trained on my code you're
welcome that's exactly what I'm going to
do
great right I needed to figure out why
this thing was infinite looping didn't I
[ __ ] how's it even
package good I have a fork that has a
couple very small fixes to
it puffer I SL
carbs that's the one that's used with
puffer Leb and also doesn't have like WB
integration for
um for like sweeps and stuff so I did
that in
puffer it's the only place that has
it nobody else is bothered to do um
Integrations as far as I'm
aware oh this is so obnoxious so there
were probably logs up here but because
this panel wasn't big enough it deleted
it what did did you change there were
just like a few path issues and annoying
things uh nothing super major uh The
Binding has some stuff though like the
the integration with W be is not
trivial for the sweeps that's in the
demo
maybe I can like pie spy or something I
see what function this is
in function is
running Ice buy work with
I don't know if I'm going to be able to
get the trace out of this but we'll
gpus if you need gpus for RL I suggest
just getting a couple of desktops not
within
chips but yeah see you around
like what the hell are all these
processes
like this is just busy waiting on
receive isn't it
threads I don't know why I have that
many
threads could be Wan be being
proces why does it not
show it doesn't show the
need that's so obnoxious how do I have
something that's that
rare I mean this is like less than a one
in a billion
eror God damn it I hate those
I mean the only thing I can think of to
fix this type of a thing which is so
incredibly obnoxious I have to kill this
process and then I have to run it in a
way that's not going
works okay so this should not
hopefully that gives me something we'll
see maybe it does maybe it
doesn't let's May fix this Shader for
now I really don't know what to do
there where
is the Gill SL nope
okay now I have code up on left
monitor can pull this
over put this here
RB is King yeah RB's awesome I'm sure
this is about to be incredibly
painful figuring out how to actually do
this but we will
persevere so what we're trying to do now
now where is
it what we're trying to do at the moment
is I wrote this
thingy that makes the mobo look more
interesting and I want to integrate this
with the actual game so that we have
this type of a
Shader um yeah and then I don't have to
draw the map manually which will so this
will probably end up actually being
faster
I just wanted to make the map as a
Shader and I figured I might as well add
a cool effect at the same
time did I have to do it this way
probably not but otherwise I'd have to
load like a gigantic map image so I
figured that this would be a cool thing
to do
load
[Music]
why does his example have three
arguments
oh cuz I'm
dumb I I am very
dumb me big
stupid very
now
initializer must be
Char vs file name hold
on
what load
Shader
zero how's it zero
now this is I'm using the C style API it
should be the same but why is it a Char
star vs file name
Shader yeah cuz I just
have this is a vertex Shader okay
Okay Okay cool so this
runs but I'm assuming yeah the thing
didn't
load it actually says that it loaded
the Shader I want the input to be on the
camera position right
why don't I see anything is the
question I should see something
screen
[Music]
in lack of syntax is just garbage on
this
let's see if I can figure out how to get
the camera position in
Bell hex blue look what's
that for
see set Shader
value texture
value void star must be C data pointer
not
okay at least that gives you error
messages
this would have unironically been easier
and see
like I'm fighting python C boundary
right now is what this
is like this portion would literally be
easier in
C okay the good thing is that I actually
do have it compiling now uh I'm not I
can't see anything yet but I should be
able to at least get the camera values
so I think now I can
technically edit the
right jeez there's a bunch of annoying
math that has to get done here
factor yeah so I think we divide
by scale factor of of more than four
it'll be like
16 at least
16 this will be
four
and it's actually probably more than
that isn't
um I need to subtract the camera offset
somehow or add the camera offset
happens otherwise the input cords are
from the screen
the input cords are from this
screen do I have this right like does
anything show up on the screen at the
moment if it's just misaligned I can
deal with that if nothing is showing up
that's hard
so I'm navigating a map I can't see
right
like oh so I'm already up here I
guess yeah there's nothing I can like
there's no like path I can take here
will I see anything
else or is that like the entire map up
there this probably like the entire map
compressed something ridiculous
terrain so what do I think
happened do I think I hit like this or
do I
think have you added logic where team
has to decide on a
lane no they should just be able to
learn to do that what I did do is I took
the distance reward out so they're no
longer incentivized to just go down mid
um however uh we're having issues with
our sweeps that are making it difficult
to rerun the sweeps
properly but no I don't want to assign
like a lane thing
evening what you're working on
so I made this Shader sweeps issue is
that the environment can there's a one
in a billion chance that it hangs and
when you run a billion steps of
experiments you get it
right um I'm trying I made this Shader
and I'm trying to just add this Shader
into the
map at the moment for the Moa
and I'm being confused about
shaders so welcome to the being confused
about shaders for now
stream what does the Shader have to do
nothing it has nothing to do with the
one in the billion bug yeah uh I just
don't exactly know what to do about the
one in the billion bug so I have this
running over here and I'm waiting for it
to get stuck and hope that it prints
something useful or I can do something
which is unlikely
but one in a billion bugs
suck and I kind of just wanted to do a
cool Shader thing so I'm doing a cool
Shader
thing race conditions H can't pie spy I
tried that it didn't give me anything on
the sub processes
I think I saw the map up top so I'm
going to see if I go see the map
look there's the map working perfectly
so it's only rendering it at the
top of the screen
I have to understand how this works
because this is not the right aspect
ratio what's the goal of the
Shader um yeah for the most part the
other thing is just like I don't want to
have to render all the tiles in a loop
it's really obnoxious so I haven't I
haven't written shaders in like 5 years
I figured it would just be a nice little
addition to this and then also if like
anybody actually knows how to write
proper shaders it's like it's now
something that people can potentially
run with and like make the MS cooler
with
right so I figured it would be a fun
addition every so often I get bored and
just want to like learn something and do
some stuff
right and I've generally found that when
I want to do something I don't really
get other stuff done until I just go do
the thing so
yeah so when it's something that's like
ah okay that'll be useful anyways I just
do
it I don't understand the input system
to this
I mean there an incoherent question I
don't know what the question to ask
hold on let me see if I can look at this
a different
way whatever came of your Twitter
article about RL and sticky actions it's
there it's online it's correct and as
further Evidence I found that one of the
best known Atari agents like the agent
57 paper from Deep Mind doesn't use
sticky action so they must know that
it's broken
too I have a Twitter account do you need
a TW do you need to be signed into a
Twitter account in order to read um X
articles is that a
thing I should just post all of them to
the website
frankly it's just annoying managing all
the different content formats but I
really should
obnoxious so the reason I do the reason
I post them on X instead of linking to
them on X is because like X just Deb
boosts all your content so basically if
you link to stuff off site nobody gets
like you don't actually get any
traffic um
yeah it's very
obnoxious they're completely out of
order really
dumb yeah I hate hostile software design
like that
yeah I mean social media's always been
garbage to be fair right like all social
m media platforms have just always been
garbage forever
ah so this is like a this is different I
see
Facebook required an
edu yeah the internet when it wasn't
designed for
just confused about what how this is
supposed to work so
how the hell is it that this is even
drawing off
screen I'm just so confused by what's
being passed
is the Shader being applied to the
screen or the
texture
like you should draw a full screen quad
using the Shader
okay good that's what I thought
um you can't just draw an image like
that
dude I don't this [ __ ] does not make any
[ __ ] sense like
how do I just give it a texture that
like
you have to set the freaking like
there's no way to set the texture from
glsl so I I have to
do
iray maybe this will at least give me an
error and then this auto complete is
garbage
um Shader
puffer oh no
wait self Dot
this why did I decide to do this today
what's wrong with me
texture 2D texture I should be loading
it as a texture
right that's what I have to
and yeah it's just self. game map stop
over comp ating it's not that freaking
hard RL do set Shader
value
texture it's self Shader texture Zero
self. game map right
good so this now
runs
and what I need to do is I need to draw
a quad
let's
see I can go find the rectangle
wi Tel
anything I'm navigating invisible walls
the whole way here which is
annoying the geometry is still here it's
just invisible
okay so it's literally there's nothing
here that's obnoxious
here does this work or does this going
to screw it up
does this now if I don't have this
should draw the map on my screen
screen but drawing a rectangle on my
screen doesn't do
this I'm confused as what the what the
hell this
is I don't think I can do this because I
don't have access to RL rectangle
do I just need to like draw a full
screen image what the
[ __ ] this is just so
stupid is so incredibly stupid e
okay so now we're drawing the Shader
canvas shouldn't have to [ __ ] exist
successfully just here
here and then
wi 255 let's try this maybe it's [ __ ]
transparency doesn't work I don't
it get rid of the break
point I can see on the other monitor it
didn't work for
weird oh wait okay so hold on it is is
getting
okay so this is interesting
right so now it does
render the
map
stretched looks stretched yeah
definitely stretched what it renders the
map and it just doesn't
do the right
location so so
right that's so trippy as well like when
you Mo move the background on the wrong
direction okay like it's not scaled
right or something but
happens order
color 16
what's the tile size for this game is
this
it something's
weird something's very weird
so I need to do the normalize there's a
normalization factor
here [ __ ] it's getting late as well I
got to order food and I got to get some
stuff done
um I'm gonna be right back I'm G to use
the restroom we're going to do a couple
things and hopefully I can get this to
work tonight we'll see
hopefully if not I don't know I'll grind
this off stream a bit or
okay I got to order some food on the
side and then we'll continue this until
it gets
here I'm hungry though and I forgot to
get lunch today because I was coding and
I started this
late for
uh I know what I'm doing
that'll be
so let's figure this out
um we're getting in the coordinates from
the
screen but they're zero to one scaled
one hold
on don't I just need to do
that's
slightly slightly tricky
um so basically I have zero to one on
both axes but the screen isn't
Square
um and and the conversion here is not
obvious to me
um it this would be so much easier if
all the [ __ ] were just in
pixels it'd be so much easier but I
guess it's supposed to work it's resin
dependent right still so much
const float
[Music]
convert
be can you do texture
size at uh at the top like this you
can't because you don't know the
texture so we're going to put it here
it's going to be texture
size
texture
Z 0
255 and then we're going to do divide by
scale
one okay so I broke something
fundamental because that should have
definitely
broken what was it
before and it
worked this was the
huh what this was the thing that
worked oh no how did I mess this
right yeah no that's that's
right and this doesn't work really I'm
assuming that this these functions are
just broken so it's not compiling failed
to link
cuz I forgot semicolons of
course you can't write a program without
semicolons okay so this
now this is the stretched version
geometry okay let's do a couple more
things let check the tile
size it's 32 as I
thought so can I change this to 32 or do
everything freaking
break okay no it works hold on let me
get it on the screen here for you
so then this is going to be 255 I
believe oh
okay something's weird with the
factor how's
though so what this is saying is that we
take my screen position
we divide it by the size of the
screen we multiply by
Factor so
wait we take where
that seems
right and then we add the camera y the
camera
is camera Target
X divide by tile size divide by
um unless wait is this because my mouse
was outside the
screen
no okay so this camera Target numbers
make no
sense draw texture stretchy stretches
already
what do you
mean what I'm trying to do here let me
explain um and I got food coming soon
but I I want to see if I can fix this
today so I have a map texture that's
like 255x 255 and each pixel is a tile
okay and then in screen space each tile
is supposed to be 32x 32 and I'm
applying a Shader to it so based on
where I am on the screen now I'm trying
to grab from the map and apply the
Shader
and it's obnoxious because since things
are not in pixel coordinates they're in
like stretch coordinates right it's very
difficult for me to figure out what the
heck Transformations are
here trying to get them to match yes
exactly and it is a pain in the ass but
if we do it we will save two really
obnoxious Loops which means that uh this
thing should run substantially faster
unless at least unless I uh until I
decide to Port it to C um so we'll save
a bunch of drawing and and also we have
some cool uh a cool little animation
that we'll get for the uh the
client there's like this cool like
border like there's like this glowing
border on the
map what is this camera Target
X is this not what I needed
size no this looks
fine but it's minus width over
I don't see how this ended up being
scaled this
way camera Target yde divide by tile
size divide by
well the camera Target doesn't make any
sense it's a 3,000
what wait we shouldn't need the camera
at all
okay print
main what's
this this
is this is cool I
it okay it's 128 so I had the dimensions
wrong
by
by this is 128
know well now it's scaled properly
because it's moving at an appropriate
actually my food here I'm probably just
not working optimally I'm like I forgot
to
eat uh no I still have another 5 10
minutes to fix
this these are like scaling past each
other it's really
so my camera position is
one to one on the
seems like there should be a big scale
factor so now I'm even more
seems like the scale factor should
actually be 32
width wait it might be times width
divide by
so take the
cord m
multiply which is going to be
32 this will be
four or even
eight
trippy this is this is the wrong
conversion
32 indices there's a big division Factor
I'm missing
here is it divide by 120 or 256
maybe 255
is this
it magic
number this looks pretty
good he this actually looks pretty
good that's the right size right this is
one tile
right this is one tile
and they look Square as
well so I just have
the
okay so now I just have the the
translation wrong is that
it but they're still like sliding past
each
other no so I have to have something
more wrong
background noise outside's distracting
me actually is my food
here I might have to pick this up
tomorrow if this is
done yeah okay this is very very close
to working um so I'm going to just
figure out what the heck is wrong with
this and then we'll have this cool thing
done um this thing is still running
right yeah so I can't tell what's wrong
with this yet hopefully I'll figure this
out soon uh a little disappointed with
the progress today but it's all right
we'll pick this up tomorrow we'll fix
some
stuff I'm uh calling it a night thanks